for some reason I feel like this night
this movie is not going to be number one
of the box office this weekend way me
love wish I grew up watching waiting to
put a television show and I used to have
all the VHS tapes in my closet nice to
watch them over and over again and I
just I adored the show I thought it was
the greatest thing I've always really
liked the woods I loved the forest I
feel really connected to the forest I've
always really liked it there I loved the
fact that it took place in the woods all
animals had their own little places to
live and stuff and it was just a great
thing for me to watch now as a kid
the plot of the movie really isn't that
big it's just a or losses Tale and
everyone starts looking for it and
through the animals misinterpretations
of various things they kind of get
involved in this huge plot that is not
even really necessary to be for them to
be involved in but they just keep seeing
things and interpreting it the wrong way
and thinking oh there's a problem here
oh there's a problem here and they just
get involved in this huge thing they're
running from something called the
Backson some monster they've you know
created in their minds it doesn't even
exist and it's just it's it's great this
is a really breezy like fun film that
really captures the original essence of
that TV show there's sonís Tabak and
they feel like a kid again I really
enjoyed it the film is done the
traditional animation which is great
because we're so bombarded by CGI
animation I'm so glad they stuck with
the original animation just like they
used to do in the TV show it's 2d it's
not in the 3d yes thank goodness for
this movie just taking it back to the
roots you know they're not trying to do
anything special or big they were able
to capture the way the characters were
so nicely Winnie the Pooh you know he's
just he's so stupid and so lovable I
love that bear his character was so
funny in this movie it was kind of cool
because you know the way this story is
is Christopher Robin is a real boy in
real life imagining all these little
characters and then we see what he's
imagining and it's funny because all of
the animals they can't spell
worth crap and it's kind of its kind of
play because Christopher Robin in real
life is a little boy and it makes sense
because he wouldn't be able to spell
either as well as he should at that age
and I just think it's kind of cool how
they used that the animals can't spell
neither can Christopher Robin but he's
imagining the animals so it makes sense
that they can't spell because they are
whatever he imagines I'm not a huge fan
of singing in films but it's used fairly
well here it didn't know me as much as
it usually does because they use the
songs for comedy the animation in this
movie I think is terrific I love the way
it looks it's very short it's only like
63 minutes long probably the shortest
film I've ever seen in theaters I also
really like the short film at the
beginning about the Loch Ness monster
overall this is just a really nice movie
that kids will enjoy and family will be
able to enjoy as well it's not like cars
to where it's purely just something for
young kids it's something the whole
family can enjoy it has something for
everyone in there there's something
special with big or anything it's just
it's just it's how way the poo has
always been and it treats it well and it
treats it with loyalty and that's why I
liked it it was it was so loyal to the
source material reminded me when I was a
kid and it was just a nice movie to
watch so I'm gonna give it one of the
poos three out of four stars I
definitely recommend seeing if you're a
fan of the show it's a good fun movie
for kids you got kids take them to it
I'm sure most of you will probably
seeing Harry Potter this weekend but one
of the poo is still a good movie so yeah
so if you liked this review subscribe to
my channel and get stuck with niced